If you want to hear about the origin of the
creatures from this movie, stick around to
the end of this video.
OK, I don't think they can hear us here...
I just ran up to the surface to gather as
many things you missed as I could from the
new movie A Quiet Place.
I'm going to try to tell you all them, and
answer some of your questions from the film.
As someone who has done sound professionally,
it should be a lot of fun talking about some
of the concepts in this movie and why the
characters did what they did.
But keep it down.
They are listening.
The beginning of the film offers a lot of
clues as to how the creatures' takeover went
down.
We see the Abbott family wander into an abandoned
town.
Yes, their last name is Abbott, it's only
ever shown on their mailbox and in the credits.
This is 89 days into the takeover.
The town is abandoned, but not completely
destroyed.
There's a board filled with missing posters,
something you've seen a lot of if you watch
Things You Missed regularly.
But this is our first clue, it tells us that
the takeover happened gradually.
It wasn't a massive attack on mankind, it
just started as a couple missing people.
There isn't really a lot of damage to the
town, but we do see a stoplight overturned,
which could also be a hint.
Later on in the movie, we see the mom go into
the basement and turn the string lights from
yellow to red.
The red lights emit a small high pitched sound,
which seems to drive the creatures crazy or
at least distract them in some way.
So likely what happened here is the creatures
struck down this light out of anger or confusion
which happens to be a hint towards what their
ultimate weakness is at the end of the movie.
So then I found myself asking: How bad is
this apocalypse though?
How many survivors are there?
The plot doesn't give us a direct answer,
but I was able to scrape together some evidence.
And as a quick side note, that's one of the
things I liked about the movie.
I was thinking recently about The Metroid
Prime Trilogy, and how unique the storytelling
is with how there aren't really any scenes
in the games for the most part, but there
is still really detailed world building and
backstory if you explore all of the world
by examining things, reading journals and
drawing your own conclusions.
I've come to call this technique "indirect
storytelling", but I had also come to the
conclusion that it wouldn't really work for
a movie.
But I think A Quiet Place kind of pulls it
off.
So, back to the question: who are the survivors.
In the first scene where the Dad lights the
fire on top of the corn silo, we can see a
couple of other fires in the distance, which
tells me that there are other survivors nearby,
but they are few and far between.
One of those survivors could be the old man
that the father and son encounter in the woods,
but I guess he loses hope when the monsters
get to his wife and he kills himself by screaming
out and letting them get him.
So the number of families near the Abbotts
is dwindling, and it's probably good that
they don't live near each other anyways for
safeties sake.
But I think there are survivors in other places.
The most interesting one to me, comes from
a newspaper headline pinned to the wall in
the basement which reads "go underground".
Later in the movie, we essentially see that
going underground to isolate any noise you
might make seems to work pretty well, because
they are able to speak to each other in the
underground nursery.
That's why I'm making this video down here.
I'd be interested to see this world through,
from the perspective of someone who successfully
hid out underground.
There could even be a whole underground city
for all we know, but if it gets too big, it
could mean trouble.
Leave a like on this video if that's a movie
you'd like to see in the future.
More evidence we have of other survivors is
shown in a scene where the Dad uses his broadcast
equipment to reach out to other countries.
We see him cross countries off of a long list,
and it doesn't look like he ever made contact
with any of them.
But that don't mean there aren't other survivors
out there, I think there are just other families
like the Abbotts, but they probably don't
have access to broadcast equipment.
And the last evidence of other survivors is
that the power still works.
They have electricity, so there's got to be
someone out there running a power plant of
some kind.
A generator wouldn't work because it would
make too much noise.
And while we're on the topic of what they
do to keep the noise level, I thought I'd
explain some of the ones you might not have
picked up on.
Some of these might be obvious but I think
you'll learn a few things.
The best thing you can do to reduce unwanted
sound is to soften the point of impact, which
slows down the impact and reduces both volume
and reverberation.
If you knock on a hard object it's obviously
going to louder than if you knock on a soft
object.
Sounds waves work the same way.
So when I record these video I use these foam
sound panels to try to deaden the sound.
The Abbotts take this concept and apply it
wherever they can.
They paste old newspapers up all around the
nursery.
They put empty egg cartons on the furniture.
Not only are they soft, but the irregular
angles bounce sounds waves in random directions
to help reduce echo.
The mobile above the baby's bed has plush
swans which should also help prevent the baby
from crying.
I mean, theoretically of course.
The Monopoly pieces they use are soft shapes.
The dice appear to be hard, which is why they
roll them on a blanket.
The daughter's room is filled with stuffed
dog, pillows and just anything to dampen the
sound.
Obviously they can't use a laundry machine,
but having a clothesline in front of the house
that is always loaded up with clothing is
a great idea, especially considering how much
of a big wide open area they live in, it could
be very helpful to dull some of the sounds
that escape the house and keep them from getting
too far.
You probably noticed that they never wear
shoes.
And a mattress is a perfect door to the bunker
because it's literally the most soundproof
thing they have.
I could go on and on but I think you get the
point.
There were only a couple questions I had about
their practices, so let's open up a discussion
in the comments.
Quietly.
First thing was I noticed they have a refrigerator,
which makes noise when plugged in.
I'm guessing they just have it off all the
time and maybe use it as a cooler just to
slow down the time it takes food to get warm.
My other question was about the fire he starts
each night.
I would think the crackle of the fire would
be loud enough to attract those creatures.
Next I'm going to talk about the origins of
these creatures.
I'll be looking to answer a few questions
like:
Where do they come from?
How many are there?
When does this movie takes place?
How is are the Abbotts able to beat them?
And why do they kill?
Based on the evidence I saw in the movie,
I think these creatures are aliens.
Remember how I said the takeover wasn't immediate?
I think these aliens came to earth in a small
group and gradually reproduced to cover the
globe.
Sound would not be an issue for them in outer
space because sound can't travel in space,
and their home planet probably has very little
atmosphere for sound to travel upon as well.
There are also numerous references to space
left by the film's art department.
The original toy that sets off the first killing
is a rocket ship.
The son's pillowcase and window have stars
on them and newspaper headlines refer to the
National Guard declaring a state of emergency.
And the Monopoly pieces used resemble a star
and planet.
So how many aliens are there?
Like I said, they multiply.
But the Dad identifies that he thinks there
are 3 in the area.
At the end, we see more than that, but I think
there are actually many many more than that.
We saw how fast these things can move.
And it's pretty fast.
But it never takes more than a few seconds
for one to strike after a noise.
There's also a night scene early on in the
movie where you can hear their cries in the
distance and it seems like there are way,
way more in the area.
When does the movie take place?
We can actually determine that pretty accurately.
The movie starts on Day 89 of the invasion.
That's the day the four-year-old dies.
His memorial reads 2016-2020.
Just over 1 year later, on Day 473, we see
a calendar dated Oct 3rd, and that's most
likely 2021, and that's where the rest of
the movie takes place.
The weekdays don't seem to line up with our
real world calendar though.
I know a lot of people are going to ask why
the daughter's hearing aid hurt the aliens.
Despite these aliens having incredibly sensitive
eardrums, we can assume their hearing works
on the same principles.
Like humans, they have a range of frequencies
that they can hear.
The hearing aid just takes certain frequencies
and amplifies them.
However, the aliens' enourmous ears, like
any microphone, are generating some self noise.
So the hearing aid is picking up those frequencies
and making them louder.
Then the aliens ears are taking THOSE amplified
sounds and emitting more self noise.
The result is a feedback loop.
If you've ever been in a video chat without
headphones, you've probably experienced this.
It's not a pleasant sound.
However, I'm guessing that the sound being
amplified is mostly outside the human range
of hearing.
But if the aliens have a wider range of hearing,
much like dogs do, the feedback loop probably
drives them crazy and hurts them.
That kind of leads into why these aliens kill.
There's no evidence anywhere of them eating
their victims or collecting food.
They probably just kill because the sounds
we make are extremely annoying to them.
Much like how I may one day kill West Dakota.
But that will have to be another day, because
today I just have to keep quiet from these
aliens.
If you're looking for some more great horror,
you should check out these island horror stories
I wrote.
Barely anyone saw this video and I honestly
think it's the best video I've ever written.
The great part is you can just throw in some
headphones and listen to these scary stories,
and you shouldn't have to worry about the
aliens coming after you.
That's gonna do it for this episode of Things
You Missed.
I can't believe it, but I somehow did the
whole episode without tipping off the creatures.
So remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week.
Ring that deathbell for notifications--